frustrating fart jokes workplace
frenemies and full-on egomania the nutty
professor might be hilarious but behind
the scenes the film was far from a
laughing matter
jerry lewis movies were popular with
kids and he always strove to make
entertainment the entire family could
enjoy while the nutty professor was of
course popular with young tykes it was
surprisingly geared more towards an
adult audience paramount was concerned
about the nutty professor because it was
more of an adult film or as adult as
jerry lewis could get as it turned out
the film was a big crowd-pleasing hit
for people of all ages while earning
jerry lewis some of the best reviews of
his career it would also be lewis's peak
as a filmmaker the ultimate culmination
of his skills as a funny man and writer
director in 2004 the nutty professor was
entered into the library of congress as
an important comedy that will be
preserved for generations to come
when eddie murphy wanted to remake the
nutty professor he had to go to jerry
lewis directly because he owned the
rights the film was going to feature a
louis cameo before he decided to back
out the reason too many fart jokes lewis
confirmed to entertainment weekly when
he had to do fart jokes he lost me
who they called my name yeah i called
you up your name it
even though the nutty professor remake
turned out well with decent reviews and
strong box office lewis eventually
regretted letting the picture move
forward lewis told entertainment weekly
i have such respect for eddie but i
shouldn't have done it what i did was
perfect the first time around and all
you're going to do is diminish that
perfection by letting someone else do it
like many comedians eddie murphy used
saturday night live as the launching pad
for his success after the box office
success of 48 hours murphy's career took
off like a rocket the actor would soon
make a trio of hits with trading places
beverly hills copping coming to america
after he made coming to america however
murphy's career took a nosedive with
bombs like harlem knights boomerang and
the painfully unfunny beverly hills cop
three murphy desperately needed a hit
and the nutty professor felt like it was
make or break thankfully eddie murphy
pulled it off and the nutty professor
was indeed a big success making 273
million worldwide it also got mostly
positive notices from critics who were
delighted that murphy was finally funny
again
not only was the nutty professor a big
hit when eddie murphy needed it it was
also the beginning of a new phase of his
career where he was doing more
family-friendly entertainment back in
the 80s murphy was known for his
outrageous down and dirty brand of
comedy in order to reinvent himself he
had to play a more vulnerable role and
leave his usual slick wisecracking foul
mouse persona behind him brian grazer
who produced the nutty professor told
the la times the only way to do that is
have him play a character that is
vulnerable it strips away eddie's
coolness for a while and is a role that
allows him not to be in control or
powerful in the beginning after the
nutty professor murphy had some of the
biggest hits of his career with more
family-friendly films like dr doolittle
daddy daycare and of course the animated
blockbuster shrek you must bleach or
something cause that is one dazzling
smile you got there and do i detect a
hint of minty freshness
he was also nominated for an oscar for
his performance in dream girls proving
he had even greater range and depth than
many people realized
in 1978 john landis established himself
as an a-list director when he helmed
national lampoon's animal house which
was the biggest comedy hit of its time
i'm a zit
get it
landis also directed eddie murphy in the
smash hits trading places and coming to
america but landis and murphy had a
difficult working relationship on coming
to america landis revealed to collider
the guy on trading places was young and
full of energy and curious and funny and
fresh and great the guy on coming to
america was the pig of the world
eventually landis and murphy patched
things up and worked together again on
beverly hills cop3 it was also revealed
that landis nearly directed the nutty
professor according to a report in the
los angeles times landis was eager to
come aboard it's not clear why he didn't
helm the movie but landis and murphy
reportedly remain cordial with landis
telling empire i see eddie around
occasionally i drive by we wave
while another landis murphy pairing
didn't come together tom shadiak who
just had a big hit with ace ventura pet
detective came aboard instead amounting
to a big step up in his directing career
in fact after the success of the nutty
professor shadyac became a comedy
powerhouse directing jim carrey again
and liar liar and bruce almighty over
time however shadyac had a spiritual
awakening after suffering a bicycling
accident in 2007 that left him with some
lingering brain issues as he recovered
he decided to sell his mansion and live
in a trailer park in malibu he also gave
away a substantial amount of money
telling cbs the more i give away the
wealthier i feel shadyac's spiritual
journey was chronicled in the
documentary i am and as he said in
pepperdine university's online magazine
the accident didn't create a wisdom
moment i simply got knocked from my head
to my heart and had the courage to talk
about the hypocrisy i'd woken up to in
my life
in both versions of the nutty professor
buddy love is an egotistical jerk some
feel the character isn't too far from
jerry lewis and eddie murphy in real
life
you rude discourteous egomaniac you're
crazy about me right and i can
understand it as landis revealed in an
interview with collider murphy reached a
point where he really got carried away
with himself murphy even admitted to the
seattle times i've had periods when i
wasn't grounded anytime you saw me in a
leather suit with a leather glove with a
ring on the outside of the glove at that
period i'm not grounded jerry lewis
wasn't exactly mr humble either as
critic jonathan rosenbaum observed in
american movie classics magazine part of
what's so disturbing about buddy love is
that lewis clearly knows him like the
back of his hand film historian jay
niber also noted in the new york post
everybody's got a jekyll and hyde
personality and buddy was jerry lewis's
mr hyde
one of eddie murphy's most important
creative partners is legendary makeup
artist rick baker who provided
pioneering effects for an american
werewolf in london thriller and men in
black to name a few baker and murphy
worked together on a number of films and
their partnership on the nutty professor
was probably their most groundbreaking
collaboration baker did the makeup for
coming to america which is the first
time murphy hilariously played multiple
characters with the nutty professor
murphy took the multiple character idea
even further playing a total of seven
people including sherman's mother and
father who make hilarious banter around
the dinner table the nutty professor was
one of baker's most challenging makeup
jobs yet he told the new york post eddie
was so polite and cooperative he
actually enjoys the process of becoming
someone else eddie would disappear so
completely as soon as i slipped that
mask over his face
when the nutty professor came out there
was no such term as fat shaming and fat
people had long been an easy target of
cruel jokes yet from the beginning
murphy wanted to show a more
compassionate look at being heavyset
before the nutty professor shoot murphy
told the los angeles times america is
obsessed with weight you have to look a
certain way there will be fat jokes at
every turn but this movie is not a put
down of fat people with at least one
plus size performer the nutty professor
hit a nerve hop singer lizzo recently
told variety that she related in an
emotional way to a scene in which
professor clump opens a drawer to reveal
a secret stash of candy lizzo told the
outlet i could literally cry right now
thinking about it people around me were
laughing but i hide food too i feel them
i feel sympathy and empathy for him
jada pinkett smith played sherman
clump's love interest carla purdy in the
nutty professor the role was a big step
up for pinkett smith's career except
that she hated the wig she was forced to
wear as she recalled on red table talk
they put me in some crazy wigs for sure
where people didn't really know enough
about black hair to know how to make
wigs and what wigs should look like
smith called the wig she had to wear a
rough one adding that the woman who
created it did not have a good grasp of
how black women wore and styled their
own hair after that pinkett smith had
her own hairdresser on every subsequent
film
while the second nutty professor film
nutty professor 2 the clumps wasn't the
box office powerhouse that the first
movie was the sequel still did well so
it's not surprising that there's been
another remake in the works but the real
surprise is who's planning the new
version james vanderbilt who wrote the
david fincher true crime classic zodiac
as well as scream 5 managed to secure
the rights for a nutty professor remake
it's strange to think that the
screenwriter behind such scary and grim
entertainment could be spearheading the
next nutty professor film and it
definitely feels like an odd fit but
maybe vanderbilt can come up with a
whole new imaginative spin on the story
for today's audiences ultimately the
nutty professor movies have a terrific
legacy the original will always be
considered jerry lewis's best known work
and eddie murphy was able to create a
surprisingly empathetic update that made
audiences howl with laughter if there
are more nutty professor movies in the
future here's hoping they can deliver
the same good message of self-love and
individuality that worked so well before
[Music]